for America's getting the Cuba is easier
but some of the islands destinations
remain elusive one such place is
something of an open secret at a diving
welcome to hardiness della Rina the
gardens of the Queen one of the largest
protected environments in Cuba the
archipelago is about six times the size
of the Florida Keys and fewer than 1500
divers per year are allowed to visit the
gardens are an oceanographic time
machine we're lucky divers witness a
healthier ecosystem a rare find among
the world's strained oceans and with
such flourishing aquatic life comes one
key feature that may leave some divers a
bit uneasy these Caribbean sharks can
grow up to 10 feet long but don't
usually consider divers edible shark
sightings can be rare in the Caribbean
but here in Hardiness de la reina sharks
are everywhere a clear indication of the
gardens resilient ecosystem and it's
healthy food chain and that's no
accident
the Cuban government has enforced
aggressive conservation measures to keep
the gardens pristine
Hardiness de la reina offers some of the
most incredible and untouched dive sites
in the world if Cuba is going to
preserve them for generations to come
the government will have to continue to
balance commerce with ecology which
means that Hardiness de la reina will
remain an exclusive destination for some
of the luckiest divers
[Music]